thoughts afterward we have a break and
then we again have an open discussion if
any questions that you have on the
program hi everyone I am Nikos uh
whatever I will present here is joint
work with my advisers Mir and wolf Kang
who are sitting C in the audience uh
we're from Northeastern University this
talk will be all about ranked
enumeration so what is ranked
enumeration uh there are many ways to
look at it uh one perspective is to
start from an enumeration problem and we
have seen talks from so far in previous
workshops and done one about the
enumeration problems the idea is that
you have a problem that has many many
solutions think of a query with a huge
join output uh maybe we can't compute
all of it at once but maybe we can
compute one answer and then the next
answer and then the other one um and in
these cases there's often an order of
importance between the answers so we
know what kind of answers we want to see
first and having a ranking function on
top of the enumeration gives us this
rank
numeration another perspective to look
at it is to start from an optimization
problem what essentially I mean a
problem with that uh where we want to
compute the best solution to a problem
and there we can ask what's the second
best solution the third best solution
and so on both perspectives lead to the
same thing ranked en numeration so it's
a very natural thing and we also have
this more cuty name like NK it's you can
treat it as a
synonym so this talk will be more about
when we can do rank enumeration and less
about the how um we started looking at
this for conjunctive queries but we soon
realized that the same algorithm and
techniques apply to many different
problems and their common link is
dynamic programming and in the spirit of
the workshop
semi so uh um here's the the structure
of the talk uh first I will talk about
how to start from a dynamic programming
problem and immediately get ranked
enumeration for it and then we'll apply
this to specifically for conjunctive
queries um okay so first let's look at
how we can see dynamic programming as a
dog we need some way to describe dynamic
programming like what actually do we
mean when we say dynamic programming and
if you open a textbook you can find a
descript I that looks like this where we
have a dag um the nodes you can think of
them as the recursive calls damic
programming or you can think of them as
the cells in your in the array that you
fill up and the edges are the
dependencies
between and we also have costs to
transition from one to the other and the
goal is to minimize the total cost
that's what we do now that's a rather
unusual way to to think about dynamic
programming so let let me show you a a
quick example of how this works uh so
this is a very very simple problem find
the longest increasing subsequence in a
list of numbers right so 3 four five six
is an increasing subsequence we want to
find the longest one uh you can do this
very easily by going Bottom up dynamic
programming at Computing at every
state um what's the maximum by looking
at all the previous numbers that are
greater than that so it's a very simple
thing and you can ask okay where's the
dug here I don't see any dug the DG are
the the edges are basically the
dependencies of the problem right um and
if we materialize them and we also put a
source in the Target node we can also
see this problem as a shortest path
problem uh and that's something we can
often do uh for these problems
um so in a sense dynamic programming and
the shortest path problem are kind of
the same problem
long right so okay you know you can say
that what's the longest path or the
shortest by flipping the weights if you
treat them as negative numbers that's
why I say this minus one thing it's the
weight of
theed okay so we have this DG structure
now usually when we do dynamic
programming we don't actually
materialize this DG but we could right
it doesn't cost us anything asically at
least uh so we can materialize this doag
as we do dynamic programming and this
will be important for an
numeration right now let's talk about
the generality of this thing and that's
where the semirings that I promised come
in uh so um essentially the question is
when can we do dynamic programming and
you can look you know at the recursive
equation that I had before from this
example you can see it has two these two
operators Max and plus and you can ask
what other kinds of operators can I put
in there and it's not surprised now that
this the answer is semi
Rings uh so I w't go through the
definition we've seen multiple talks
today yesterday uh what I want to point
out is that this works for dynamic
programming but now if we want to have
ranked numeration we need something more
than that and we discussed about this a
bit in Co deep talk yesterday the
additional property that we want is
selectivity from the plus operator
essentially we want the the plus
operator to act as a
comparator uh it has to return either
the first argument or the second one and
semirings that have this property are
sometimes called selective
diodes H if we have this property the
natural order of the semiring that we
can Define actually has a total order on
the
domain here are some examples of
searings we've seen the Samar
Rings yesterday and today and they have
appeared all the time the first three
ones the tropical the V and the Boolean
semiring they all have selectivity and
we can do rank numeration for all of
them the question makes sense for the
last one this uh natural number semi
ring that's a semi ring that we use to
count things right we can count the
number of solutions count the number of
paths and if you think about it it
doesn't really make sense to ask for a
second best
Sol and that's because of selectivity
it's the lack of selectivity
okay now we have this order now um and
what we can show the proof is very
simple I won't go through it but
essentially we can prove with
distributivity that it has a certain
kind of
monotonicity uh if we start with some
inequality X less than y we can multiply
on both sides the same thing and the
inequality continues to
hold okay um and
this property is also the same thing as
the optimal substructure property in
dynamic programming if you think about
it what is the essentially what it says
is that if you fix an optimal suffix
subsolution then you just need to pick
the best X or Y to to find the overall
op solution right so that's what dynamic
programming does
um okay so with these semi Rings The
Selective D we get a certain kind of
monotonicity but here's where things get
interesting because there are also other
kinds of monotonicity in
particular uh in work on instance
optimal Alber uh there is another kind
of monotonicity that I call here
holistic monotonicity just to be able to
differentiate what it says essentially
is that if you have an aggregate
function and you increase all of its
arguments then the aggregate function
can only
increase now the ontic we are talking
about for for semiring is actually
stronger than that because we need to be
able to do that for any subset of
elements for example if you pick here
three and four you can replace them with
two and eight think of about this in
terms of the tropical semi ring because
3 + 4 is less than 2+ 8 we can
uh we can swap three and four with two
and8 and the inequality continues to
hold this kind of monotonicity I call it
here subset monotonicity for this reason
it has been used in the past for rank
enumeration for conjunctive queries here
in this paper from Benny and yasa given
in 2006 um and it's essentially where
dynamic programming leaves and where we
can do rank
numeration um okay now let's talk about
the
algorithms
yes right so the the ranking function
essentially this you can think of the
ranking function as this F it's a an you
define an aggregate function on the
query answers and you get some scores
right and then you use the scores to
rank the the query result or if you
think about it in terms of semi Rings
you use the the the times operator of
the semi ring to get the scores for each
individual query answer and then the
second operator the plus which is the
comparator to do
the it don't require any
no that's it I mean it depends there is
a subtle difference on whether we talk
about you know H semi Rings or aggregate
functions uh but so for semi Rings we
need all the the properties of the same
I but for aggregate functions you can
think of this simply like that you know
you aggregate some numbers and then you
compare your your quer
ansers question so is subset uh mostly
always defined so is the order on a
subset always defined as the order on
the sum of the
elements so here you see that 28 is
greater thanal to 3 four because the sum
is greater yes so essentially you have
to use the F here if this this F is the
sum then you're also taking the sum of
three and four to to to do the
substitution so f is like a f is the sum
here okay
yeah and I assume ranking functions
don't have fixed AR right
this number it depends you can yeah so
if you think in the world of aggregate
functions you define the function as
operating on a multiset right that's the
usual way to think about aggregate
functions you can take any list of
arguments and you collapse them into one
thing but of course you can also Define
it on a on a
fixed
right um right algorithms so it
shouldn't come as a surprise now that
since we can see these problems as a dog
that um in order to do rank numeration
we need to to find the cas shortest path
in the Doug um so essentially we're
talking about algorithms that can do
this case or the path
calculation um and this is the best we
can do for subset monoton ranking
functions um this time to this ttk
function here it means the time that we
need to get the K answer in our
eneration time to k um and we have to
first pay a linear cost uh that's the
sizes of the graph or the state space
and then for the K answer that we get
back we have to pay a logarithmic Cost
Plus this L is the size of the solution
because we have to write it out
so you can see this is already very good
right because the the first part is
essentially the cost of dynamic
programming and for the second part we
have this logarithmic
cost now if you know about a numer if
you have heard before about aeration
algorithms you know that um usually
there's a pre-processing phase and an
enumeration phase and that's essentially
what we see here the the first term is
the pre-processing and the second term
is the enumeration
um you may have also heard about delay
for eneration Al so I think that's a
good point to talk also about that
um so essentially what's the difference
between the time Tok that I just showed
you and the
delay so if you are if we are interested
in uh getting the answers as quick as
possible the time to K is the measure
that captures that delay is more about
the having regular inter arrival times I
have here an example on the right the
x-axis is the time the y- axis is the um
the number of solutions returned and we
have two algorithms algorithm a and
algorithm B um you can see that the that
algorithm a returns every solution
faster than algorithm B but it has a
high
delay here algorithm B on the other hand
is more regular but it's lower so there
are three things I want to point out
here if we can bound if we can upper
bound the delay we also get an upper
Bound for the time to K so that's good
because we can use delay as a a
sufficient condition to to get time to K
now if we start from an algorithm that
has an already good whatever good means
time to K having this additional
restriction of a regular delay can slow
the algorithm
down and and finally if we talk about
lower bounds instead of upper
bounds h lower bounds are more
General now it should be clear that for
if we talk about the specific problem
and we take the best blue algorithm and
the best orange algorithm the blue one
will always be on top because it has
less restrictions right but I think a
very interesting question here is
whether this gap between that I'm
showing here is actually real
or not in other words does there exist
there are there cases where we observe a
large gap between these
two and I have two partial answers for
that question uh the first answer is a
paper by floran Capell and Yan streski
where they look exactly at this question
and they show that you can actually
trans translate the time Tok into delay
for unranked
enumeration uh with a logarithmic
cost the second partial answer that I
have is that for the ranked enumeration
that I'm talking about here we actually
do have an an we observe an algorithms
that um has a good time Tok but its
delay is
not so let's talk about this algorith
this algorithm we call it anyk part plus
um on the left we have the guarantee
that I showed you before and you can see
um what we improve is this logarithmic
Factor instead of log K we have log n
where n is the the number of nodes in
the graph now why is this better for
small values of K these are the same
because the the first term this the size
of the graph dominates for large values
of K and K can grow a lot because you
can return many many solutions for
example it can be n to the power of L
this expression there we see an
improvement now you might think okay
this is a rather small Improvement right
because it's the logarithmic Factor uh
but I think what's interesting here is
that if you run this until the end and
you get all the answers sorted this is
faster than sorting so it Returns the
answers faster than a generic
comparison based
algorithms okay um what I didn't mention
is that this new algorithm requires a
stronger notion of
monotonicity uh which I call here strong
subset
monotonicity um more most of the the the
ranking functions or the searings that
you can think of actually are in this
green box but we also have examples of
some that are not and I have here an
example
um let me show you what this
monotonicity property is um I have here
the definition on the top um but
let's let me show you an example so that
you get the gist of it um on the left we
have the tropical s ring and for this
semiring this has the strong subset
monistic property um the way to think
about this is that we have an observer
that is looking at the output of A
ranked enumeration algorithm and it's
trying to infer more
things about it for example let's
suppose that we get these three things
in the output in this order like one one
one one one2
141 what we want to be able to do is to
uh figure out what will happen if we
swap a prefix of the solution like the
ones with the two right greater prefix
and for the tropical searing it actually
works out that if you substitute one
with two you keep this kind of
monotonicity and the algorithm actually
this is what it does it keeps track of
this information it stores it and it
reuses that to infer more comparisons as
it goes on and
on for the one on the right this doesn't
hold
so what is this we have minimum and
multiplication and we also have a zero
on the domain which is an
an so what's happening here is that what
can happen is that the algorithm start
returning first 099 and then
011 right which if you multiply these
numbers they're all zero so it doesn't
really matter and we don't learn
anything about what will come after that
so we can't infer from that that you
know 199 will be better than 111
so that's the essence of this property
that by looking at complete Solutions we
are able to to um to figure out more
things okay and finally I have here a
slide with um the history of this thing
I mean as you can imagine this is a
fundamental problem a Cas shortest path
problem and this is my best attempt to
summarize what um
what what what has happened like all
these papers and ideas
um there are many details here what I
want you to take away is that there is a
line of work that starts from ller and
morti this is a well known it's called
ller MTI procedure and this one uh
results in this algorith that I call
here NK part and there's a different
line of work starting from belman and
calaba in the 60s which results in this
NK Rec algorithm and the new algorithm
this NK part plus I mean that's that's
how the name came about it it
essentially combines conceptually ideas
from both of them and that's how we got
this Improvement for for strong subset
monoton okay so now how much time do I
have left like 10 minutes okay so um I
will talk about how now to take this
framework and apply it to conjunctive
queries
um here's an example we have a three
paath query it joins three
tables and we want the query answers to
be returned ER ranked by a sum of
weights and the weights are these
columns that so so you can imagine that
every table has an additional column
which describes the importance of a tle
right and we're saying we want the query
answers that have the uh smallest sum of
weights
first so what do we do here uh it's uh
we can take this and we can map it to
the framework that we just saw because
we can create this white nodes for the
for our
tuples um so you can see there are three
layers of these
white white nodes one for each relation
and uh we can also take our weights and
we can put them in the Ed in the edges
of our graph that's fine uh one more
ingredient that we need is this form of
factorization here this is only to keep
the size of the representation small uh
because you think of this as a bipartite
graph right if if we do do uh all the
possible connections we can get a
quadratic cost so the these intermediate
nodes here yal 1 yal 2 only serve to to
make the representation more
Compact and I'll just mention that you
know this is a natural way to think
about many types of uh not not only equ
joints with the equality conditions but
also about other conditions essentially
how do you connect these layers and we
have all done this also for inequality
joints
okay so if you do all that essentially
you get this dag right and the dag has a
source node it has a Target node and
every path that starts from The Source
not to the Target is now a query answer
there's a one to one correspondence so
we can just apply what we did before and
we get our rank
numeration this works for any query that
has this path structure and one relation
comes after the other but you know in
general con queries can be more General
than that and we have seen multiple
times in different talks in the past
about the joint trees um a joint tree is
um a tree where we can put an atom of
the query or a
relation in every node and there's a
certain connectedness property and every
asly conjunctive query has a joint
Tre so there's a very natural
progression now to think about this
problem I showed you what happens for
path queries with whose joint re the
path uh we can also have three queries
which joint three is actually a three
and of course they can also be C click
but that's an orthogonal concern because
we can use hyper 3 de compositions to
map them back to uh queries um so
essentially what missing here is this
middle part right I we need to take what
we did before and generalize it to
handle the the three case and I won't
have time to show you how this works but
you know essentially um there is notion
of dynamic programming that works on
trees I call it here three DP it has
also been called in the past nons serial
dynamic programming um for every
algorithm that we have we need to go
through a process of uh translating so
that it works on the three case and we
have done that and the results look like
this now this is the results that we get
uh in terms of
complexity I want to highlight two
things first if we if you think about
data
complexity then there's really no
difference we are here and there's no
difference between there are many
algorithms that satisfy this and this is
the same guarantee that I showed you
before this n plus K log
J if we go to combined complexity and
now we also have the size of the
query um this is where we observe the
difference for this more advanced
algorithm so for Combined complexity and
strong subset monotonicity we get this
Improvement
here um which there if you see there's
this diam of Q This is the diameter of
the
query so this is a what happens when you
try to take the the results and
translate them to the tree case it gets
a bit tricky but the gist of it is that
the more path like the query is if it
has a high diameter and it looks like a
path the more Improvement we get on the
other hand if it's like a star or very
bushy we don't get much improvement
okay uh also we have implemented this
and it actually works very well in
practice um I'll just show you one
experiment here this this is one query
uh on the x- axis we have the time and
on the y axis the number of answers that
the algorithm returns and you know if
you try to First do the join and then
handle the ranking you won't see any
answer uh for 10
seconds uh this is our implementation of
this join first strategy but you know
you can also run it on database systems
post SQL here and Commercial system
system X now the the order between these
two doesn't really matter sometimes one
is faster sometimes the other one is
faster the um the important message is
that they always follow this joint first
approach um on the other hand our NK is
much faster it Returns the first answer
here 500 times faster and it can also
have an advantage even for the last
answer because of this faster than
sorting okay I don't have a lot of time
but I want to highlight one more thing
that I think is uh interesting here is
that so far I've been talking about the
ranking function and its monistic
properties kind of in isolation but if
we take both the ranking function and
the query structure into account we can
potentially get
more uh there are two aspects that I
want to to show one is about
lexicographic orders and noar will talk
more about lexographic orders in the
next talk uh in a lexographic order the
the ranking function says we care first
about X then about Y and so on one way
to handle it is to map it to a semi ring
and employ the framework and the
Machinery we have from before if you do
this you will get logarithmic
delay but now for it turns out that for
certain orders you can actually get
constant delay and there's a very easy
way to see this for example for the
query we have here this is the same
graph that we constructed before observe
that if you start from the left and you
go to the right you will always
encounter first X then y then Z then U
right so if you just do bread first
search you you get rank numeration for
this order and it turns out that for if
the order somehow agrees with the qu the
structure of the query you get this
constant delay this has been observed in
factorized databases the the condition
that they use is a bit different but
it's essentially the same as an alpha
elimination order
um the other aspect that I want to
highlight is this notion of a
compatibility with
um a three DEC composition or a joint
Tre and this is something that uh from a
paper by Paris and saline deep
um an easy way an easy example to
understand this is let's say I give you
a function like this where it's G of XY
plus G of y z where G can be anything
right any function now this is not
subset monotone because we don't know
anything about G right but if you look
at the Joint of the
query H the G functions will resolve
locally in each bug and in between the
bugs there's only a plus right so
actually we can do this for this
specific joint Tre and there is this
notion of the ranking function bit being
compatible with a certain joint or 3D
composition um have a couple of minutes
okay so very quickly what we just show
is that you know rank enumeration the
same algorithms appear in different
settings and the common link is dynamic
programming and semi rings different
monotonicity Notions can give us
different algorithms and we could
potentially do more if we take the
structure of the query into account we
also have some this is what I showed you
is very practical it actually
outperforms database systems if you
implement this fortive
queries uh and I have here some
questions that are very natural given uh
I hinted at them multiple times during
the talk we still don't have a precise
characterization of tractable queries
and ranking functions so if you think
about this outer holistic monotonicity
class we don't have algorithms but we
also don't have lower bounds so a
concrete example is the median as an
aggregate function we don't know what
happens there um the other thing that I
mentioned is this relationship between
time Tok and delay we have some results
but we don't completely understand what
uh the relationship between between them
and whether we can always map one to the
other and I think you know an
interesting question is about circuits I
presented to you here something that I
claimed is a general dynamic programming
framework you know
ciruits also claim to have this property
I think it's clear that you can take
what I showed you and map it to a
circuit uh but what's not clear is
whether you can carry over all the
algorithms so I think there's some
interesting questions to look at there
um and that's all thank you
question yeah so it's really impressive
that your impation is faster than the
commercial ones even when youer full
result so why are they slower so is it
because of a back plan or because of
like are you a really M hacker or
something right um so I think your
question is how this Gap here right the
this 1.6 times or even with the the
other systems um so there's many
explanations to this first of all it
doesn't always happen right it happens
for some queries one reason why it
happens is that we are reusing
comparisons as we are doing the uh the
an numeration and the query answers
they're not independent objects right
they they have a shared structure that
you can exploit and that's essentially
what the algorithm does if you use a
generic you know merge short or quick s
on the query answer you are treating
each answer as an independent object but
you can exploit this the sh structure
the fact that they all come from the
same database and the same input tools
to speed it up um and that's why it
happens but you know it doesn't happen
always it depends a bit on the structure
of the
query more practitioners question is so
I think it makes a lot of sense do that
you you can beat database instead of if
you want like to 10 or 100 but what do
you think be the right way to push these
ideas into a commercial system so do you
need redesign a system from scratch and
having like anation as a first class
citizen or is there any way P this ideas
kind of reusing existing Machinery that
they yeah I think that's the right
question going forward I don't have the
complete answer I mean of course I can
say you know we need to implement this
as new physical operators and do
everything from scratch I think it's a
one of the most important questions
right now how you can map this to what
database systems already do and somehow
Express this as with their primitive
operators
anys uh
no then let's let's take this for
afterward session very interesting to
hear yes but let's let's well let's get
okay thank you